[موسيقى] أجنبية
هذا سؤال جيد حقًا لدي
طموحات لدي أفكار ، بعضها
يعمل ، وبعضها على حافة
عدم العمل على الإطلاق ،
ولا يزال لدينا بضعة أيام كما تعلم ،
لذا فهذه هي  هو ما أريد أن
أفعله
أريد أن آتي إلى هنا وأريد أن أذهب
وأحتضن هذا العالم وأريد أن
يحتضننا هذا العالم وأريد أن
أحمل على الأرجح أفضل القرارات
التي أعرفها في العالم
وسنحاول أن نفعل شيئًا
مميزًا ولكن الشيء الوحيد الذي لن
نفعله هو أننا لن نعرض
لك إطارًا واحدًا من الفيلم ،
لذا فإن الفكرة هي الاستماع إلى الموسيقى اصنع
قصتك الخاصة في  رأسك سأشاهد
الفيلم الذي ستتذكره أو لأنك
ستتذكره بشكل خاطئ وهو أكثر
إثارة للاهتمام لذا فأنا أريد
أن يكون الجمهور مشاركًا في هذا وأنت تعلم
أنه ليس فقط نحن على المسرح
نلعب معك أنا  أحتاج إلى ملاحظاتك ،
أحتاج إلى الشعور بها ، نعم ، أحتاج إلى
الاتصال الذي تعرفه ، وبالتالي فإن أسهل
طريقة للاتصال هي عدم وضع الأشياء
بالطريقة التي لا أملك فيها موصلًا على
سبيل المثال ، فلماذا تريد أن تذهب
وتذهب  إلى حفلة موسيقية ورؤية عودة الرجل
طوال الليل ، أعني أن
الأمر ممل جدًا ، لذا
أتيت من فرق موسيقى الروك أند رول ،
لذلك أعامل الأوركسترا
مثل هذه الفرقة ، كما تعلمون ،
إنها كذلك
ولا أفعل.  فكر على نطاق صغير ، لذلك
هناك الكثير من الأشياء على المسرح